[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nous avons aussi une
rude journée aujourd'hui nous sommes
allés à la télévision chercher toutes
les lettres que vous nous avez écrite et
notre nuage est bien chargé gros ours et
transformer un facteur pour la
circonstance je veux moi le facteur pas
trop j'y vais oui vas-y de l'ours
bon je prends mon sac où aucune lourd ce
sera cool là au plat et fait attention
de ne pas tomber
monsieur le facteur peur risque pas trop
j'ai le pied marin
[Musique]
moi je t'attrape et c'est moi qui vais
peut-être appeler au moulin rouge qu'est
ce que c'est c'est le facteur suis tombé
ferait encore tomber oh là là sauf
celles facteurs suite au but de tuer
maladroit ce la faute de toutes ces
lettres que je vous apporte le sont trop
lourdes et mercy 12 à fond non nous ne
nous affolons
l'a1 et des mois les enfants ont posé le
sac
alé lô ou options on ouvre le saccage la
voilà mes lunettes
non mais bon il y en a aussi pour ulysse
et pour moi voyons vous avez en voici
une belle adressées at il oui et un
mihrab cher mirabel cher petit louis
city je suis très mécontente des bêtises
que vous faites à nounours j'aime
beaucoup
gros ours et j'espère que vous ne
recommencerez plus signé béatrice quelle
charmante enfants une autre non non non
celle là elle est pour ulysse cela ça
c'est un très beau dessin mais il ya
aussi une laie cher petit ours
ah bon alors je m'appelle brigitte et je
t'aime beaucoup
tu es très drôle quand tu agis tu t'es
grosse patte hood
oui patron ça c'est un télégramme à
urgent stop il faut aller au dodo stop
unissent alors les enfants allez vous
coucher sagement tout ça je vous laisse
les lettres vous pourrez les lire demain
au revoir il faut que je me trouve par
l'hélice macro des météorites à aller au
bal ans à l'école toi vite
[Musique]
bondy petit louis
bonnet mirabel bonne nuit tous les
petits enfants embrasser bien fort vos
parents est allé sagement vous coucher
alors notre facteur la tournée est
terminée ou non patron faut que je me
dépêche
j'ai beaucoup de lettres attribuées et
bien en route
connus des enfants
nous viendrons vous voir dimanche soir
bonne nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
où